foreign good evening and welcome to
Tucker Carlson tonight so if you've been
watching the news recently the one thing
you know for certain about the accused
gunman and the massacre in Colorado over
the weekend is that he was a crazed
right-wing anti-trans extremist this is
a man who's radicalized by this show and
by the Twitter account lives of tick
tock to hate transgendered people and
that's why this man walked into a bar a
gay bar with a gun and started murdering
people he did that because he was taught
by right-wing media Outlets to despise
and fear the non-binary community and
that's why this show analybs of tick
tock must be hauled into court and
bankrupted for what we've done so that
we can never provoke this kind of
horrifying violence ever again that's
the real lesson of this mass shooting
so that is what they've been telling you
again and again and again on various
news channels for the past three days
and we're not overstating that by the
way here's a selection of it
it's a campaign being driven by members
of Congress and conservative influencers
on social media as well as the Wright's
most favorite TV Network FOX News those
incidents at drag events I mentioned a
few moments ago they happened within the
context conservative media personalities
fear-mongering against queer folks
respected Messengers from TV networks
saying that these people are wrong and
they're trying to damage your children
we have a long history of the lgbtq
community being victimized demonized by
especially right wing media and
Republicans you have
anti-lgbtq rhetoric dispute on the most
watched Hours on FOX News at a regular
clip against the U.S military against
gay men and women against gay teachers
against their right to exist
so Fox News in its most watched hours is
attacking even the U.S military and of
course gay men and women and teachers
too they're advocating quote against
their right to exist in other words
they've been calling for genocide that
would be us
now that's a stout claim but no one has
made it more often than NBC News in
particular it's too self-described
disinformation reporters Ben Collins and
Brandi zadrosny these two are outraged
that anyone would dare criticize the
genital mutilation of children or drag
shows for fifth graders or creepy weirdo
teachers explaining the mechanics of
oral sex to nine year olds pointing out
that any of that is happening is hate
and it gets people killed here's a
highly emotional Ben Collins of NBC news
making that very point yesterday morning
am I doing something wrong here
are some headlines that I wrote the last
six months
fueled by internet's far right machine
anti-lgbtq threats shut down trans
rights and drag events remember
there's a drag event happening in
Colorado what do what do we do about
public officials at
local level state level Federal level
who try to inject the fear of the very
word transgender into school issues they
get more clicks for it and they end up
on Tyler's and they end up on the
highest rated show on cable news and
last night by the way
Tucker uh attacked my colleague Brandi
zadrosney who was co-biling around
almost all these stories not me Jack
Brandy of course but he attacked Brandy
um and he he went right back into this
idea that someday
is trying to groom your kids trying to
sexualize your children right yeah who's
the they first of all yeah and second of
all all of her reporting was right
it was right
oh it's all about me of course says Ben
Collins but more to the point how dare
anyone criticize the August
disinformation reporter and former
College librarian Brandy zadrosney
because as Ben Collins pointed out her
reporting was right
well since you brought it up Ben Collins
was her reporting right
well not entirely do you remember when
Brandi said drozni told you several
hundred times that the accused shooter
Anderson Lee Aldrich was inspired by
hatred for the non-binary community that
he learned on this show do you remember
that
well actually it turns out we discovered
last night that Anderson Lee Aldrich is
drum roll please part of the non-binary
community he doesn't hate them he is one
in a court filing aldrich's lawyers
wrote this quote Anderson Aldrich is
non-binary they use they them pronouns
and for the purposes of all former
filings will be addressed as mix Aldrich
mix Aldrich that's the shooter the
non-binary shooter
let that sink in
first get your chuckling under control
and Ponder what this means what it means
is that virtually everything that NBC
News has told you about this shooting in
Colorado is not only wrong it is the
opposite of the truth it is all a
grotesque and filthy lie it wasn't news
reporting it turns out to have been the
most transparent sort of political
propaganda and for once they have been
busted flat out in public trying to sell
political propaganda to an unsuspecting
public under the guise of news
it's not the first time they've done it
they won't stop doing it oh but they did
it a lot in this case here's another
clip another instance of Ben Collins
trying to once again pass off political
slogans as news
there are five dead people
in a strip mall because that was the
only place they felt safe as gay or
trans people in this town in Colorado
Springs
he's emotional telling you that there
are five dead people in a strip mall
because that was the only place they
felt safe as gay or trans people in this
town of Colorado Springs
so it turns out it's the town's fault
too because there are a lot of
Christians everybody knows in Colorado
Springs so gay people feel terrified
there because Christians are dangerous
and all these terrified gay people were
huddled together for safety when this
Fox News adult anti-trans bigot walked
in and started shooting them for being
trans Folk
that was Ben Collins's quote reporting
well the only problem is not all the
victims Were Gay one of them at least
one of them was at the club with his
girlfriend oh details details Ben
Collins doesn't let details get in the
way of an effective political attack and
it would have been an effective
political attack had not reality
interceded but he doesn't care neither
is the White House here's the White
House telling you that because in
non-binary person shut up a gay bar you
can't own a gun
this attack also comes amidst a rise in
violent rhetoric and threats against the
lgbtqi plus people across the country
while we don't know yet for certain the
motive of this attack
hate has no place in this country and
neither do military-style assault rifles
which is why we will continue to push
for an assault weapons ban
of course it makes sense you find the
reasoning so when the trans community
opens fire on itself we need an assault
weapons banned because why because
you're a hater
Pete butter judge of course couldn't
pass up a moment like this it's not like
Pete but a judge wants to talk about how
things are going over at the
transportation department when she
supposedly runs short answer not well no
he put a judge wants to talk about
identity he always wants to talk about
identity and the funny ironic thing is
until just a few years ago but a judge
wouldn't even admit that he was gay he
hid that and then lied about it for
reasons he has never been asked to
explain why not but whatever now he is
happy to use his sexual orientation as a
cudgel to bash you repeatedly in the
face into submission quote here's the
latest if you're a politician or media
figure who sets up the lgbtq community
to be hated and feared not because any
of us have ever harmed you but because
you find it useful then don't you dare
act surprised when this kind of violence
follows don't you dare act surprised
don't you dare all right fair enough we
won't dare but honestly we're a little
surprised to learn that the anti-trans
shooter is himself trans
were you surprised by that Pete but a
judge now that you're admitting you're
gay after lying about it since we're
talking about identity what do you have
to say about that well nothing weirdly
people the judge hasn't said anything
nor is he apologized for attacking other
people on false pretenses
guess who else hasn't apologized Ben
Collins or brandy Z drozny yesterday
they were accusing us of getting five
people murdered now that the story they
were telling has turned out to be a lie
the opposite of what they said it was
they're pretending that nothing has
changed at all
or they are liars cold-blooded Liars
it's amazing to watch and so is the
company they work for NBC News just ran
this article after we know that the
shooter was himself trans they ran this
headline with a straight face quote
right-wing influencers and media doubled
down on anti-lgbtq rhetoric in the wake
of the Colorado shooting
can you imagine writing that knowing
what we know they had no problem with it
then an editor at NBC called Benjamin
goggin added this quote if the shooter
is non-binary it doesn't change the fact
the right-wing media is continuing to
stoke hatred towards lgbtq people after
five people were killed at a gay bar
right so it's hatred
so if you're against genital mutilation
of children or bringing toddlers to drag
shows you're against the lgdpq community
well of course that's insane
there's nothing anti-gay about that most
gay people aren't in favor of General
mutilation or bringing toddlers to drag
shows
there's nothing wrong with those
opinions they're the right opinions that
all decent people understand that what
is indecent what is wrong is lying about
a mass shooting which NBC did
so how are the rest of the media
handling this well CNN for its part is
just denying that the shooter is really
non-barrant binary couldn't be it
couldn't be just couldn't be true
so they've decided to continue
misgendering mix Aldrich watch this
attorneys for the accused shooter
Anderson Lee Aldrich say in new court
filings tonight that the suspect now
identifies as non-binary
in a footnote to emotion asserting legal
privileges the public defenders say
quote Anderson Aldrich is non-binary
they use they them pronouns are you guys
lawyers
I mean you know I don't know if I I
don't know what to say about that I mean
that's what he's now saying it sounds
like they're trying to prepare a defense
against a hate crimes charge
so in this case if the shooter claims to
be non-binary he's got to be lying about
it it's not real
so we're not going to call the
non-binary shooter mix or observe his
pronoun requests in fact the whole
pronoun thing is gone biology is back he
was born a man he's still a man
oh it's unbelievable so what they're
doing of course is using an actual
tragedy the murder of five people
for political reasons and of course it's
not the first time they have done that
they're happy to use death for political
Advantage they did with George Floyd did
it with officer Brian sicknick
and it's not the most
recent anti-gay attack by the way that
has turned out to be a total lie
perpetuated by the media just a few days
ago a guy was caught throwing a rock at
a gay bar in Hell's Kitchen New York on
camera so the media judicial interviewed
the owner who said quote it feels like
yet another manifestation of hate
against our community a lot of big
social media accounts ran with that
story more hate more hate it
so then this story didn't get quite as
much coverage the police arrested the
guy who did it his name is Sean Killian
and he was upset because of a dispute
involving a friend he didn't Target the
place because it's a gay bar in fact and
we're quoting now from The Rock thrower
I'm gay myself
I would admit that they
slandered half the country on the basis
of wrong facts no never admit it never
apologize keep moving on pick another
story to beat you over the head with
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight